on se bouscule à paris pour obtenir un
autographe de xavier dolan et pourvoir
en grande première européenne son
nouveau film intitulé ma vie avec genève
dans nos veines ce qui est super positif
jusqu'à maintenant que ça fait du bien
de sentir le film attendu puis d'avoir
des gens qui sont au rendez vous donc
oui je suis super heureux d'être ici
avec des vedettes internationales comme
kit harrington et susan sarandon ma vie
avec john f dans nos veines est un des
films les plus coûteux de toute
l'histoire du cinéma canadien 37
millions de dollars
ce film sur la célébrité les faux
semblants xavier dolan le présente avec
émotion mais je suis tourné en anglais
est destiné au marché américain
l'accouchement du film ma vie avec jean
lève dans la zone a été laborieux le
tournage a été arrêté pendant six mois
xavier dolan a tout réécrit lors du
montage il a même supprimé des scènes
avec une des vedettes
jessica chastain comble de malheur une
fois complété aucun distributeur
américain ne s'y intéresser et c'est ce
qui explique pourquoi le film n'est pas
encore présente au québec
le distributeur doit organiser soit
organisée une sortie je crois nord
américain donc ça n'inclut pas que le
québec ça inclut continent c'est plus
c'est plus compliqué si les
distributeurs américains et êtes à
embarquer dans l'aventuré
c'est en partie parce que les critiques
anglo saxonnes ont été sévères après une
première projection au festival du film
de toronto de voir john a qualifié le
film de totalement raté le global mère
lui a donné une étoile sur quatre
l'agrégateur de critiques rotten
tomatoes indique que seulement 13 % de
ces critiques ont aimé ça dit donc un
désaveu des intérêts et y est certain
qu'un distributeur américain qui
regardent ce qui veut s'embarquer dans
cette galère majoritairement financée
par le secteur privé
ma vie avec jean lève dans le voeu n'a
reçu 5 millions de dollars de téléfilm
canada et de la sodec producteurs et
distributeurs soit maintenant présenter
le film en amérique du nord d'ici la fin
de l'année
entre qui se négocie mais et
le distributeur veut sortir sur notre
territoire nord-américain en entier en
attendant xavier dolan à une autre film
en chantier - un vent denis je peux pas
m'asseoir dans mon salon qui attendent
pendant trois ans que le film ça faut
que je continue avec ma vie faut que
j'écris quelque chose ici louis philippe
ouimet radio qu'un dans mon frère